the Kaos is hiding in what's irrelevant
and so and that's very interesting
observation because since the chaos is
virtually infinite it's a real questions
where the hell do you put it well you
put it in what you ignore and you can
ignore it as long as it isn't actively
interfering with your movement forward
you can assume that it's that it doesn't
matter that it isn't matter that it
doesn't matter same thing all right so
here's the kicker there's one more class
of things that you can run into along
the way and this is where the chaos
breaks through so let's say you're
moving from point A to point B and
something that you don't expect
Oh curves and it gets in the way so
let's say that you're living with
someone and maybe you kind of like them
you're not married
so you don't like them that much because
otherwise you'd ask them to marry you
but anyways and so how quarter of youth
is looking for something better and 3/4
of view is half satisfied something like
that and then person because we're
ambivalent about such things and then
the person you discover or the person
announces that they'd be having an
affair okay so then how are you supposed
to respond emotionally to that well the
part of you that wasn't all that
committed to the relationship is kind of
exhilarated by that and then the 3/4 of
you that's half satisfied is hurt and
and you're going to exploit that part
for sure in the ensuing discussions and
not mention the oh that's kind of
exciting that you you know betrayed me
that way so so but the point is is that
you that's a whole now what's happened
as a whole has you have this structure
that you're walking on like ice like the
thin ice that you're skating on and now
there's a hole in it and the hole we
don't even know how deep the hole is but
you know there's a hole there and so now
you're anxious about it though maybe
also a little bit excited because god
only knows what's down there but but you
don't know how what to do with that hole
because it could spread very badly on
you it could be that you know the whole
relationship was a facade
and that all your relationships have
been to saw facades and that the reason
that is is because you're so damn
shallow that it's impossible for you to
have a relationship that isn't just a
facade and that's partly because you
don't pay any attention to other people
and it's also partly because you're
malevolent and selfish so that's a nasty
thing to discover or maybe that's the
sort of person that you're attracting
which would make sense actually if
that's the sort of person that you are
and so so there are certain things that
you can encounter that basically unglue
you and what happens is that those
moments of being unglued travel up that
entire hierarchy of presuppositions
right because the one of the logical
conclusions to being betrayed in a
relationship is that you are that you're
truly a bad person now another equally
logical conclusion is that the person
that you're with is really a bad person
and another logical conclusion is all
people are truly bad people you know I
mean it in microwave that in microwaves
you can't trust anyone you can't trust
women you can't trust men you can't
trust human beings you can't trust
yourself the whole place is a
catastrophe it's a nightmare well then
you can fall through into chaos now the
way your body responds to that when some
or maybe you know you're supposed to be
getting a promotion at work that's good
you're all chipper about the promotion
at work and you you walk into your
boss's office because he or she wants to
see you and they say wow you know we've
reviewed your performance over the last
few years and your performance has been
somewhere between mediocre and decent
and we're downsizing and see you later
that's not a raise or a promotion that's
for sure not so whole that you fall into
and the question is well what do you
make of that right how do you frame that
how do you take that emergent chaos and
make habitable order out of you don't
know is the whole capitalist system
rotten to the core I mean that's a
convenient explanation under those
circumstances that's for sure were you
working for a psychopathic son of a
bitch did you make the wrong choice in
university and was that your father's
fault because you never did what you
want
with a year fault for not standing up to
them or is it a dying industry or is
maybe this a wake-up call that you
should go do something else that you've
been waiting to do you know that you've
actually wanted to do your whole life
and that's why you're doing such a
miserable job at your current occupation
because you're bitter and resentful
about the fact that you never did what
you want you don't know it's all of
those things at once and that's very
stressful because all of those things at
once is too many things and that's the
reimburse of chaos that's the flood
that's the return to the beginning of
the cosmos that's another way that it's
been represented mythologically it's
like you voyage all the way back to the
beginning of the cosmos when there's
nothing but undifferentiated chaos and
that's what you're confronting and maybe
it's too much for you and often it is I
mean that that can really that can be
traumatizing it can hurt your brain you
know it's just too much for you to bear
but doesn't matter you're stuck with it
and so how do you respond to that well
some of it is catastrophic negative
emotion you're freeze and that's
protective and maybe you don't even want
to move you don't want to bloody well
get out of bed for a week and that's
because your body is reacting as if the
bedroom floor is covered with snakes and
the best thing for you to do is just not
move just freeze not a pleasant
situation to be in because it's you're
hyper aroused very very physiologically
demanding and is zero about if it's
productive except maybe the snakes won't
see you but they've already seen you so
that isn't helping very well so you've
got all this I'm different you've made
it negative emotion anxiety fear hurt
anger guilt shame emotional pain the
whole plethora of catastrophes and then
maybe on the other side lurking down
there is thank God I'm done with that
you oughta just bloody well hated I
dragged myself off to work every day and
there's a little part of my soul that's
a goddamn happy I finally got fired that
I can hardly stand it you know maybe you
don't even admit that to yourself
because well that would mean that all
that time you spent at the job was just
some cost you're deluding yourself the
whole time I mean haven't an interesting
thing to consider though sometimes if
you're in the unpleasant circumstance of
having to fire someone
you know sometimes firing someone is the
best thing that can happen to them which
doesn't
you should go out and much enjoy it
although I have met very disagreeable
people who actually enjoyed firing
people I'll tell you a story about that
at some point it's quite interesting but
you know sometimes if someone's just
limping along in their job and doing it
as musically and wretchedly as they
possibly can imagine the best thing you
can do to them for them is to say you
know you're failing at this and and that
doesn't necessarily mean that you would
have to be failing at absolutely
everything else in the entire world so
maybe you should just accept the dam
failure and go off and try something new
and I mean that's terrifying for people
and I know they hate it and all that but
but but sometimes it's better than the
alternative which is just slow torturous
death